this is perhaps the most joe biden thing
i've ever seen
joe biden has been a senator a vice
president and now a president himself
there's been a lot of
change in his political career over the
years but the one
constant is that joe biden really really
loves ice cream he talks about it
literally all the time no matter what's
going on no matter if he's a senator or
a sitting president no matter what
crisis is sitting on his plate
just get that man a cone
yeah he loves ice cream because he never
has to worry about brain freeze
everything else yes all right
i'm beginning to think a lot of people
don't like white people
and ironically a lot of them are white
people too just ask lockheed martin the
nation's
largest defense contractor last year
they sent their white male executives to
diversity training camp
the purpose to break down their white
male privilege
and here i thought that was the views
job in the city
journal chris ruffo explains how white
employees are forced to atone for their
putrid pale
pigment these workers include retired
air force colonels
generals and also the dudes who run the
1.7 trillion dollar
f-35 fighter jet program but they're
caucasian men making them as
white and useless as a really bad
lacrosse player
because you know they're white
there the employees were asked to list
connotations for white men
what was listed can you guess racist
angry old anti-women
aryan nation kkk guns
basically how cnn described trump voters
the conclusion white men don't care
about diversity and refuse to give up
their power so we need to cure them
these guys were then forced to embrace
an inclusion philosophy
that only includes them if they admit
that they're the problem
sounds like cat's marriage counselor
but apparently they have it so good that
they're the only ones you can be racist
to
the resources behind this seminar can't
believe they used that word
are all about uncovering roots of white
male culture and heterosexual
heterosexual privilege they point out
that
positive traits like hard work and
principles
are devastating to women and minorities
if i were a woman or a minority i'd feel
insulted
i wonder if you identify as one would
that get you out of this stupid seminar
so we live in a world where expecting
hard work for minorities
is racist and telling white people
they're intrinsically evil
isn't employees then must rebuild their
identities
as agents of change by reading over a
hundred white privileged statements
where they confess their acts of bigotry
one example quote i can commit acts of
terrorism
yeah that's exactly what i look for in a
weapons maker
if it sounds like a cult indoctrination
that's because it is a cult
indoctrination
all that's missing are the extra wives
actually
calling it a cult is a smear against
cults this is basically a cult
without the fun stuff you get the
humiliation but none of the drug-fueled
orgies
i wonder if cnn is bothering to cover
this or is it too close to their own
left-wing brainwash
let's see what's on that network right
now i
hate white people so much because your
wife is
a a monster of energy there
these evil white men had to read
statements from fictitious minorities
and women
that explain how bad white men have been
to them one of them was
quote i'm tired of hearing of the
concept that we should be colorblind
sounds like someone hates martin luther
king jr too they have more in common
with george wallace than george floyd
so the whole point of an integrated
society is now irritating to our modern
race warriors
maybe because if everything isn't racist
they're out of a job
i wonder what our angry white male
[Music]
thinks
yeah critical race theory seems to have
seeped into every part of our society by
now
except one the inside of my head
[Music]
something wrong with him so why would
lockheed martin greenlight this idiocy
well what do they make baskets and
flutes cute hats for
bunnies no it's air and missile defense
systems fighter jets
essentially they sell things that kill
people
and not just white people brown ones too
and they make billions off it
you can go on investopedia and check out
their products but you'll also find just
as important their commitment to
diversity
inclusiveness and social
responsibilities
those are their words meaning what
they'll kill people of
any color no it means that the missile
destroying a village was brought to you
by a non-binary person of color with a
degree in gender studies
you see what's going on right
corporations have finally figured out a
way
to defang the hard left the anti-war
crowd can easily be appeased if you just
go woke
and play the i'm the worst race ever
card it's the best distraction since
texting while driving
a pacifist might be disgusted by
lockheed but what if that fighter jet
has a rainbow bumper sticker on its
fuselage
and guess what the cockpit is now called
a non-binary inclusion space
in which the aviators drop projectiles
on citizens from above
non-binary citizens you know i've been
trying to figure out who's behind woke
culture
i thought there was no head on this
snake but i think i'm wrong
it's the corporations they finally
figured out how to placate the left
and that's to throw their white
employees under the m1 abrams tank
on one hand jeff bezos is supporting
black lives matter in the other hand
is the steering wheel of his 500 foot
yacht
does it make for better products no does
it improve race relations
not by a long shot but it does put a lot
of money in the pockets of diversity
coordinators and other grifters
and a smile on the face of filthy rich
executives
like a bomb it makes for a hell of a
racket in more ways than one welcome
tonight's guests she's the only
vegan we're afraid will bite us fox
business network anchor jagen mcdowell
[Applause]
he's the only dallas cowboy who married
a dude
as far as we know anyway former
annabelle linebacker jeff rohr
if he looks familiar to you he probably
was the dunk tank operator at your
favorite carnival
fox news radio host jimmy failure
she's very bold her hair is gold and
every day she gets more old
boss news contributor cat tips
you know jeff i was trying to find a
funny way to introduce you and i
couldn't think of anything funnier than
you being an nfl linebacker for dallas
cowboys who then married a guy who looks
like liberace
it's true i did i enjoyed liberace this
is a younger version of
liberace but uh it's an interesting
thing to actually be an nfl player an
nfl player and be married to somebody
like liberace and it opens a lot of new
doors it
does so with this stuff this woke stuff
this
critical race theory how would it how
would it have been
uh encounter how would have been greeted
by the cowboys back in the 1980s
if you can if you were sober back then
and could remember what it was like
it would not have worked especially on
that team i would have been off that
team they would have never drafted me in
the first place
um but when i did get there we had a
hell of a lot of fun greg
yes yeah a lot of orgies a lot of ex
and the nfl was out of control back then
yes it was so this
has it changed i mean this stuff this
stuff can it work in sports
or is it impossible with that mindset i
think it could work in sports but
i don't think sports wants it to work in
sports especially pro football
you know baseball's super macho too
basketball definitely no
so it's going to be a very long time
till there's out players
in the nfl nba or the mlb maybe pro
soccer
yes you know uh dagin how do you think
this training
actually makes white men feel i hope it
makes
all men i think that you should have
training for all dudes
i hope it makes them feel awful they
need they need to be indoctrinated into
what it feels like to be a girl
like simulated monthly cramps with a
cattle prod
repeatedly poked at your crotcheler
region
i priced out cattle pods on amazon
four out of four and a half out of five
star rating on amazon
a cattle prod it's only 63.98 so
you could make that financially feasible
for a corporation
or teach men what it feels like to wear
high heels just
pound their tiny little toes with a
rubber mallet
or just tell or just tell them smile
why are you smiling oh did your latest
husband leave you you
had to turn that frown around so i i'm
all for
um male training but not this kind of
male training
that kind of male 1 this kind of male
training exactly
i think that's called marriage by the
way that's what turned him gay
he was married to a woman that
yes yeah that happened to me several
times
jimmy it looks like you actually mugged
liberace's wardrobe closet with that
jacket
um is this kind of it it does feel like
a cult
yes this is the thing and by the way to
the point of your intro i did work a
dungtang by the way
i bet you did yeah i so have a dunk tank
vibe even though now i'm dressed like a
stripper who got fat during the lockdown
and i can't get any work well god fell
to book me yeah and thank you barely uh
thank you uh point taken um this is very
much
a thinly disguised way of going to the
dominatrix it's the same experience you
get called names you have to apologize
for existing
the only thing they're not doing is like
putting a cigarette out on their tongue
right it's the same thing
in the past these corporate ceos would
get in big trouble because they'd have
these eyes wide shut parties
where everybody would get debauched and
drunk and naked and demeaned and abused
now they just get called racist for an
hour and a half but the real problem in
this country is we don't have a white on
black problem in this country
it is a white on white problem that's
the problem in this country
is half of the white people in this
country are hating the words of martin
luther king judge you by the content of
your character not the color of your
skin
the other half is telling the black
community you're under attack everybody
hates you we're out to get you
and none of it's true black people we
love you if you don't believe me look at
this fashion what other white guy is
wearing this idiotic outfit
it's swag because we love you so i don't
understand the correlation
between your jacket and that but i i get
your passion and i understand it
all right cat this is really now he says
it's more like masochism i think it's a
distraction
away so companies have figured out a way
to
make people who hate corporations happy
yeah especially if you make
weapons i love that you pointed that
because it's
crazy like there it can be no such thing
as a woke progressive weapons
maker i mean it's beyond parody like
don't worry
all of our bombs were made by people of
color like they're
bombs you're making weapons to destroy
and kill
there's no kumbaya about that whatsoever
it's a very bold marketing strategy on
their part
but there's no such thing as a woke what
like it's just progressive
that we have the diverse people made the
things that kill the people
what are you talking about well think
about the empowering message though that
people are going to be blown into
millions of pieces knowing they did so
in the name of progress
you're a dust cloud progress guys make
bombs
guys make purses some guys are better at
making bombs some guys are better
there's a lot of guys in this not any
women that's my huge
well okay you are you are our kind of
like our business
expert here will companies actually push
back and to push back you have to like
look at
what's being coming out of your own
internal human resources
because this that's where it's coming
from it's not coming from outside
it's coming from inside the house
somebody in
and by the way they're lockheed's using
a company that was founded by two white
guys
yeah that's who's doing the training at
lockheed it's somebody internally who's
telling them
in order to hire people you need to do
this level of training
it's worse when you're talking about
consumer products brands
who have gone so far left eventually
it's going to bite them in the ass
because they're going to alienate
more than half of their customers so
true can i say one thing to your point
that's so brilliant it's that they've
tricked the people
who used to listen to rage against the
machines right to joining the machine
like you literally went from listening
to raging as a machine too you're in the
machine
making stupid for the government it's
such a great
racket i admire it now now i think i'm
gonna be pro woke
all right we got to move on hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else